i've always had like because
i don't know if it was just my school in
australia but like you know when you
watched like american uh like high
school movies yeah and that had like the
cafeteria like yeah
well there was like the lunch lady and
they were yeah this was like the serving
of the day you know kind of [ __ ] like i
don't know why did you look at that and
go like i wish i had that in my school
well i think americans wish they had
that in there yeah yeah i mean like like
because i remember like watching
american high school movies and i'm like
damn i wish my high school was cool like
every simpsons episode
i watched and like bob was in the
cafeteria i was like man that looks
[ __ ] cool what does every american
school have that lo and behold i know
not every american school has that yeah
i was just shocked that everyone had
cars
that's what blew me away
yeah there's like it's like a 15 year
old kid yeah yeah yeah yeah he's like
yeah i'll pick you up tonight i was like
it was like do you mean your parents are
going to pick you up
i don't know what was going on in the
2000s but like every single thing it
wasn't about like if you had a car it
was like which car you had yeah yeah
yeah
you all have cars it's like it's like
yeah it's like oh sorry i'm gonna go
pick you up when did you guys first like
learn to drive then did you learn how to
drive like immediately when you could
or did you yeah like when i a
complicated story oh for me it was like
the moment you hit 16. was complicated
about it
what how did this be complicated so i
started learning how to drive when i was
uh
17 which is when you did in the uk yeah
yeah yeah but what sucks is that because
my birthday was in july which is the end
of the school year people who who
started in september had already like
way past got their cars and were driving
the school yeah it ends in july oh sorry
ends in september sorry september no it
starts to start starting ends in like
august yeah yeah what yeah really yeah i
don't know if we're talking about that
way when is yours it's january
what the school year starts in january
yeah
what it ends in december starts in
january
okay so wait wait how do some holidays
work for you then summer holidays is
december but then when do you get
christmas holidays
so you end so
actually it technically starts in
february so we end school middle of
december and then you celebrate
christmas and holidays during holidays
and then all of january's summer
holidays and then you come back so how
long do you get off them during summer
holidays yeah like depends on the school
but like
usually like a month and a half okay
okay like
nearly three months because it's pretty
much
the first half of august is when it ends
right yeah yeah yeah and then well we're
talking university or were we talking
like secondary
section second group both are the same
right yeah for us it was all the same no
no in university i remember in
university you get like [ __ ] three
months off and those were like those
that was like before that
like school holidays for me were always
the summer holiday was six weeks it was
always six weeks winter holidays winter
holidays was two weeks and then we'd
have like half terms where you'd get
like
where you'd always where you'd get like
one week off like halfway through the
summer spring and autumn yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so all together we got
like
we got we almost got like about around
two months of holiday that was spread
out yeah and then like university here
and i remember thinking yo what the [ __ ]
we get three months off
for like
we get three months off for summer why
am i even going to [ __ ] education
anymore man
the first time i experienced the first
like summer holidays in uni i was like
well
see you at university never again
i remember
i remember when some holiday started in
university i'm just like well i'm just
not gonna go back to uni yeah
that's three months right that's like
you know you know what you can't imagine
the end of some holiday yeah yeah
um but yeah so the point was that yeah
basically kids who are born in september
uh sorry [ __ ] am i saying i'm checking
my ass kids who had their birthday like
in my year who were like really close to
the start of the year yeah basically
got to have their license and already
had it right
right yeah [ __ ] um and you were right at
the end yeah
yeah so they were in my year because it
didn't matter if you're the year above
because you weren't friends right yeah
even if i was closer in age technically
so like the the people who got it first
were like the coolest ones oh yeah cause
it was like everyone was like oh can can
we get give me a lift because
oh i'll drive you there it's like yeah
wait
is that is that way so it's like for for
in the uk
you guys have like different stages in
your driving license right like you have
like learners yeah with like provisional
stuff like that yeah so when you're on
your first level
yeah
so you have it or you're learning okay
so when you're all learning can you just
like drive by yourself no no okay no you
you have to have someone in there you
need to be
someone who's supervised yeah okay
supervises you and has how many years of
experience x amount of years right
driving yeah and you can't go on like
the highways yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so
like it's only until your provisionals
that you can drive by yourself right
yeah yeah but the problem is that
normally not that you can't find someone
that you can't get a car yeah yeah yeah
you need to be insured and that was what
the hard part was because insurance for
like a 17 year old is you're definitely
insured yeah you need to be insured no i
could i could just use my mom's car no
you might have had family insurance oh
maybe i don't know but like if yeah even
if if you are under family insurance
your price gets like tripled if you have
a life if you have a 17 year
yeah yeah it's insane like the reason
why i was just like no one owned a car
except for a few people yeah was because
the the insurance cost was like triple
or quadruple the car yeah right right
the car was nothing like my mate got a
car for like 100 quid off some guy the
insurance was like a thousand plus yeah
so it was like jesus yeah yeah it was it
was more cost for the insurance than the
car itself the lessons were expensive as
well i did lessons my brother had
already passed and you know so it was my
turn
i was doing it and it was going well and
then every now and then the the guy
would just kind of call me up because i
was learning through a guy yeah that was
how you mainly learn in the at least the
countryside yeah okay and he was
kind of flaky he was kind of like he
wouldn't show up sometimes and then
sometimes he would just stop
and then
i'm i'm about i want to say two-thirds
away from getting my test
and he just calls up and he's like oh
yeah by the way uh i've quit i'm just
not doing any more i'm not doing i've
i'm sorry that i don't want to do wow
instructing uh people because the costs
on the car are too much and stuff yeah
yeah oh
oh okay uh all right well so i thought
it can't be too hard to find another one
my mom just could not find another
instructor because they're all booked up
because there's not many in my hands
during your learning stage right yeah
yeah yeah normally like they're they get
booked up pretty quickly because there's
not that many because yeah very
profitable yeah really like doesn't make
much money and it's a lot of work
um and it's a lot of upkeep on the car
as well yeah so he did that and and then
i couldn't i couldn't find one for like
i want to say right up until like three
months before i was leaving for
university right so i had to get back
into it it'd been like a six seven
months because i couldn't find anyone
yeah started doing it again
and i was kind of getting okay at it and
i was maybe like i don't know
i want to say like 10 lessons off
doing the test right i'd go to
university right and then i just didn't
do it yeah of course because like busy
having fun yeah because like and you
don't need a car in university no
definitely yeah i didn't and um you know
i
didn't have my license and then it
became something that i was kind of like
okay don't really want to do this
anymore because it's kind of in the way
yeah it's really pain in the ass and i
have to start from zero again and if i
did do it i thought i'll do one of those
like because you can do like a week
intensive course yeah yeah you just
drive like eight hours a day yeah and
you do your test and hopefully you pass
statistically they're like the worst
drivers yeah but you know because you're
basically speed running right yeah yeah
yeah so
so i you know i i'd gone through all of
uni never did it and at this point like
in the uk you have to have two things a
theory test and a practical test yeah
theory is really easy but it only lasts
two years after you've done it so mine
had expired right so i had to go and do
it again right yeah so i was in london
and i was like oh [ __ ] okay i'll go i'll
go and get it i'm gonna actually learn
to drive yeah and then i booked one of
these courses that was like really
expensive yeah for like five days yeah
and their like promise was you will
guaranteed get your license by day five
and anyone who says guarantees
guaranteed guaranteed together
that's as [ __ ] up
so i i started driving yeah and i had
this guy and he was well
great as well she'll be really nice i
could bribe him
well he wasn't like he wasn't testing me
but
and you're also allowed to use that
person's car for the test and stuff
right you know it's really good he was
nice start you know he was like oh
you're welsh good good i like wash
people we were both in london so it's
kind of like oh nice nice he was really
weird
he would also take any opportunity to
insult women drivers
he was really weird i'm about to commit
misogyny
every
and also you would sometimes you know
because you're in the car for like six
hours seven hours yeah right you know
you'd talk about life and stuff he would
bring up some things and he'd bring up
some of his his views on the world yeah
that you'd be like
yeah yeah yeah terrible yeah
yeah situation can't stand it we're
parking by the way
how long where are we going
my dad
my dad as well kind of has like that
weird like he creates these like
stereotypes out of nowhere when it comes
to like driving
so we now do not think about it i'm like
every time i remember there were moments
where like my dad would be driving my
dad will say he doesn't have road rage
he absolutely [ __ ]
like i don't care what he says because
every time i remember like every time
he'd be on the road and there'd just be
like someone who's like taking him off
for whatever reason he'd be like oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] move and then he'd you
know get into the lane look and dead and
like do the luigi death stare yeah and
they'd be like oh it's [ __ ] volvo
drivers i'm like
i don't think every volvo driver is
necessarily a bad driver like bmw
drivers yeah like a massive [ __ ]
what is your personal vendetta against
volvo yeah because like i remember like
the one of the biggest stereotypes was
like asians are like bad drivers right
yeah and like i don't i don't think
necessarily asians are bad drivers i
think asians just drive by the rules of
their own country exactly which is just
like a [ __ ] free-for-all yeah like i
remember because like i remember when uh
when i first learned how to drive i
didn't actually first learn how to drive
uh in the uk yeah right so i believe
like john turns up in the uk
yeah so so what happened is um so i was
like turning 17 that year so i could i
could uh learn how to drive in the uk
but i believe in thailand like uh you
can like start learning from like 16.
i'm not sure if that's i'm not sure the
exact age
but but i i remember i could legally get
lessons to learn how to drive so i was
just like right when i get head start on
learning how to drive before i start to
drive in the uk so i go so i start
learning to drive
in thailand right in bangkok right
um and um
it's like the dark souls of driving yeah
it's it's like the dark souls of driving
so like i take a few lessons there and i
get you know i get pretty confident in
driving in bangkok with thailand rules
right so so you know i can i can
competently handle the car and uh
definitely competitively handle traffic
you know what i mean uh and so i
remember i i go back to uk and i turn 17
and i sign up for my first lesson um and
then
i uh so the instructor turns up and uh
you know we just have a casual chat
before before we start driving
um and uh then he asked me oh have you
had like any experiences or did you like
use your provisional license or whatever
and i'm like yeah yeah yeah you know i
i've actually i have i've actually like
learned how to drive in thailand like i
said this like with confidence like i
know how to drive you know breaking it
yeah i know i drive the car i've uh i've
started to learn how to drive in uh
thailand you know i've pretty confident
on bangkok road so you know could you
repeat that
and so you know so you know i i'm pretty
confident about it so so it's like okay
okay so let's let's get let's get this
first lesson started then and so
immediately i just drive off and he goes
stop
you've immediately failed
because i didn't check i didn't check my
mirrors
i know that i know they they do this to
be like
they just want you to do it you don't
understand but like that the guy how i
had right when i was doing this it's
like he couldn't just say you did
something wrong it had to be this whole
ordeal where he was like that's a really
good turn for a [ __ ]
it was like nothing could be every
single thing had to be packaged with an
insult it was like yeah that was really
good on the roundabout if you wanted to
kill someone if you're a woman yeah
oh you didn't check your mirrors like a
woman yeah he would do this all the time
it was so infuriating because i was just
trying to get good and every single time
i'd be like how was this he was like
that was great if you want to kill
someone right and i was like
just tell me how it was at least at
least for you it was just like not
checking your mirrors like my
my uncle failed his first driving test
because he was like all right get in the
car check all the mirrors all right
let's drive off it's like stop you've
immediately failed you drove out the
exit
all right so he literally got in the car
to didn't even make it out of the
driveway and he was like you've
instantly failed come back tomorrow yeah
because sucks i mean you do it don't
they yeah because like i remember when i
learned how to drive in england i
basically had to re-learn driving from
like what i was taught in thailand
because in thailand they they teach you
like awareness and control but uh like
like vehicle control but like in the uk
it's all about here's the procedure
check mirror hey check mirror b check
your blind spot yeah yeah yeah check
your blindfold
i get it but like in in thailand it's
just like uh you you must learn to
become super saiyan ultra instincts this
is how you drive this is the best way to
take a hit from a car
if someone hits you on the head that's
how you curl up directly
they take the least casualties
he's gonna inflict maximum damage on
[ __ ]